je pense je pense qu'il avait repéré la
bête à qui pensez à les repérer la bête
ghislain public peut-être qu'il avait
repéré la bête ah bah faut suivre les
amis hommes ne sont pas payés à un homme
s'est pas l'agent de rocco siffredi non
ouais norbert j'ai trouvé est ce que
c'est une bombe atomique oui c'est une
bombe atomique c'est qui mais il paraît
et qui peut être une bombe atomique
écoutez le prétentieux il a dit ses
jardins de luxe info pour lui était de
lorient 9 ans la fin de mes 29 ans j'ai
rencontré laurent et comment alors
commencé à rencontrer on s'est
rencontrés grâce aux réseaux sociaux en
fait il m'a envoyé un message sur
instagram pour me demander plus de plus
d'information sur la pratique de
l'électrostimulation budget des
centrales sport on avait déjà déjà vu
bah oui je pense qu'il avait dû repérer
la bête la bête donc voilà en tout cas
ça a été un moyen d'entrer en contact
donc on est allé boire un café on s'est
très bien entendu on a passé un super
moment les a tirés de base excusez moi
je vous coupe mais vous êtes intéressés
il ya un jeu de séduction très
rapidement mais il m'a proposé dès le
lendemain un dîner un peu rigolo que je
me suis retrouvé chez line renaud voilà
c'était hyper agréable hyper sympa et
puis après on dit qu'on est rentré tous
les deux et c'est là qu'on a on a
commencé à sortir ensemble
l'été 2012
il est en cours phase d une photo
officielle parce que franchement là les
phototypes activités selon thierno bah
là franchement elle a aidé sarkozy et
carla bruni à se rencontrer
j'aimerais ce que tout ce que j'ai
retenu c'est on s'est vus on sait bien
aimé on a pris un café est sûre même ont
couché ensemble
ça c'est ton côté et on sait ce que j'ai
entendu un malentendu ça c'est le côté
un peu les gars fonctionne comme ça donc
ils ont dû fonctionner comme ça sert de
plus romantique comme à lens avec la
rhétorique c'est ce que j'ai entendu non
et le soir me tue a dit le soir même on
a eu un café le soir même mais on aura
90 j'ai dit que le secoue naples n'a bu
un café le lendemain on est allés chez
line renaud on a passé une super soirée
on a commencé à sortir ensemble analysé
de racisme ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que parfois sortir ensemble c'est
s'embrasser c'est pas décemment baiser
t'as pas couché dans l'illinois l'état
dans lequel faisait des crêpes
mais rien vu je le soutiens
[Applaudissements]
je ne dirige pas le premier soir
attention à oui je suis je ne couche pas
le premier soir je t'embrasse et ce
soir-là il donc ça a été le début de
notre île et a commencé après à bout de
caen même temps vous aider ou bombe
habitent ensemble quoi où tous tu te dis
c'est sérieux ah bah en fait la semaine
d'après on est allé à santorin ensemble
on a passé un super moment et là on
s'est dit vraiment dit qu'on voulait
construire quelque chose on a vu passer
plusieurs jours on a beaucoup échangé on
s'est dit que voilà qu on avait tous les
deux les mêmes envies à savoir
construire quelque chose de sérieux
qu'on n'était pas là pour pour que de la
rigolade quoi en bonneterie j'ai
commencé on s'est vus du coup une
semaine après le thé à santorin semaine
d'après human target
[Applaudissements]
je n'étais pas trop passionnelles ce
n'est pas que passionnels nationale
c'est à dire c'est ça une relation
c'était juste match décrit la salle
faller passionnel
qui a passionné la première semaine
l'amour aujourd'hui on met d'accord
après y'a pas que le sexe dans la vie ça
c'est sûr et oui c'est une fille c'est
une fille qui a joué une copine à moi
qui m'a donné un jour le meilleur
argument pour coucher ensemble le
premier soir à minima je couche toujours
le premier soir pour être sûr de pas
tomber amoureuse d'un mauvais coup à
celles ci ne sont pas ensemble mais
c'est bien que développé des sentiments
et après qu'on couche ensemble on est
déçus les normes et web loupé des
sentiments ni le sexe n'ont jamais mis
le doigt sur un truc très important et
sur les sites de rencontres parfois les
gens te disent d'abord on prend un verre
et oublie souvent je disais à l'époque
je disais pardon tous ensemble et
appellent parce que par contre le plus
beau mec du monde tu fais du bouche à
bouche à noisy elle ressort viré mais
non latchimy pas victor les femmes ne
coucherait si sa part madame les soirs
jésus terreau ça se passe pas comme la
future série qui parle d
je connais que ça les femmes tout va
bien sûr pas le premier soir c'est quand
tu veux une relation sérieuse c'est
souvent bien je pense à toi peut-être un
peu vieux jeu mais d'attendre une
semaine ou deux voilà
tu gâches je pense qu'elle
lui fait qu' un peu l'expert ici sont
chacun fait ce qu'il veut ça combien de
temps attendre si longtemps de toi le
plus longtemps une femme tape à xiii a
longtemps c'est combien bienvenus
l'équidé keller
[Applaudissements]
dans la dernière question la dernière
question pour isa je respecte est très
jeune mais qu'un petit tu peux inconnue
un peu plus jaloux ce n'était pas clair
ma question toi que tu as rencontré son
mari est ce que ça se faisait le 1er
soir mais moi j'avais les scieries qu'il
fallait faire vite parce que comme ça
c'est fait
[Applaudissements]